spent a lot of time telling you how the
cities are falling apart and most of
them seem to be but not all of them are
here's a pretty amazing success story
we're not exactly sure why it's
happening we're going to try and find
out right now the city of miami
is on track for the lowest crime rate
since the 1930s
since al capone moved there
why what are they doing that no one else
is doing francis suarez is the mayor of
miami he joins us now mr mayor thanks so
much for coming on i wish we'd done this
story earlier i wasn't even aware of it
till today what exactly are you doing in
miami that america's other cities are
not doing
well i'm going to blow your mind away we
actually increase funding for police so
we have the most police officers we've
ever had in our history
we've also
lowered taxes to the lowest level in
recorded history which has prompted
tremendous growth we grew 12 percent i
think it's the second most in recorded
history as well we have a 1.4
unemployment we're the happiest city in
america and the healthiest city in
america so it turns out if people are
healthy they're happy they're working
they're not paying a lot of taxes and
they see
an increased police presence uh they
don't have a tendency to to commit
murder
um and and that's what's uh been the
miami miracle story uh which is a huge
contrast to the washington nightmare
story that you've uh you know you've
articulated tonight and over the last
few weeks
so there's this great video floating
around the internet i assume it's real
of the riots in the early summer of 2020
and they
people came to miami and decided they
were going to riot and all these miami
cops come out come out of a patrol car
and say no it's our city we don't we're
not doing that here we're just not doing
that did you ever have meaningful riots
in miami
we really didn't because like you said
we drew the line uh in the sand and we
said you're not going to hurt people
you're not going to destroy property
that's something we're just not going to
tolerate in our city and so you know i
think the first night we had
some some issues but right away i think
it was pretty clear that we weren't
going to tolerate it we weren't going to
accept it and so whoever came in from
out of town obviously realized that
miami wasn't a place i was going to
accept that kind of behavior and left
and went to somewhere else to to create
havoc over there
what's so funny is that for a long time
beginning in
probably around 1980 for at least a
decade after miami was famous fairly or
not for crime it was a whole tv show
about it miami vice
is it kind of weird to be now famous for
being safe
you know i grew up in miami i was born
and raised there i was born in 1977 you
know in the 80s we had 300 plus
homicides right now and i knock on wood
here in the in the studio we are at uh
28 year to date uh so from 300 plus uh
to 28 and we're hoping uh the trend
continues for the rest of the year and
uh there literally we had to look back
in our archives to see when was the last
time we were ever that low and so like i
said you know it's really a a trusted
and true uh you know formula for success
we keep taxes low we keep people safe
and we lean into innovation to create
high-paying jobs it's uh sort of the the
miami story and uh it's something that
should be scaled across america
it's pretty incredible murders are the
one thing that are pretty easy to
measure so there's kind of no lying
about how many murders you have that's
why it's just no lie
absolutely
mr mayor thanks so much for joining us
francis suarez of miami
thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight